what's up marvel fans we're here with
john favreau who plays happy hogan now
you started the mcu directing marvel
studios iron man what is it like to
continue that legacy of iron man as
happy hogan well i love being a part of
this as an actor because i get to
continue to work with the people that i
work with on the iron man films
also even before i started directing i
remember visiting the set of of
spider-man 3 that was my first
experience
so it all feels it's nice that it's all
coming together and i'm just happy that
i've been able to be a part of it in one
way or another for decades now
that's awesome well now the entire world
knows who spider-man is how does that
affect happy
well it's you know happy's always been
in on the secret with tony stark uh with
with peter parker so happy was always
good at being a professional wingman to
help out and make help them navigate
their way through all the challenges of
uh of being a superhero i think he
offers a lot of moral support i don't
think he's
i don't think he's too good for
protection even though he's supposed to
be head of security but i think he's a
good friend and i think for peter parker
he was a good uh
i think he took it upon himself to look
after him after tony was gone so i
really liked playing that part and i
really like tom holland a lot and i love
i love popping onto the set and working
with uh john watts and everybody there
uh it's a great group of young actors
and as an actor i love it and i think it
comes through in the character that's
awesome now do you have a favorite mcu
moment in spider-man through your
journey
oh and spider-man i like when we're in
the bathroom i think we're in the
bathroom together
where i'm trying to be like nick fury
popping into his high school
and i and i confront him
and uh and someone flushes the toilet so
my really cool like nick fury moment is
completely undermined
by uh by by a toilet flushing yeah i
like that one a lot that's awesome john
thank you so much enjoy the movie thank
you have a good one
[Music]
you